government hi I'm Lauren hello we talked
a lot about business and everything yeah
help do you see any trends and
particularly k-12 education I teach
middle school you know I have an app to
text my students and their parents
before you go uh-huh
sixth grade um but do you see any trends
for me to use with my students to
connect with parents anything like that
so allow me to like stand on a soapbox
for two minutes and I'll answer your
question I am flat yes here's the
biggest trend I see that the way we
educate our children right now is so
broken
it makes me actually want to slip I
believe that most teachers that I know
that are paying attention do because
actually here's the problem we are
asking my permission I don't point you
you're gonna follow like I get how it
works it's not it's not capitalism in
the school systems um we are teaching
our children to memorize [ __ ] and then
regurgitate it in a world where
everything they lose the ninth present
in the United States history
this old bugger that is like it is
ludicrous what we're doing right now we
need to completely reverse it which is
they could memorize the [ __ ] at home or
don't memorize a law because it's never
been less valuable to the information
smart than it is now because anything
you want to know is right here remember
remember some of us older ones remember
what it was actually interesting to be
information smart that ship has sailed
I don't care if you know something I can
tell you the same thing in four minutes
four seconds eight seconds it's right
here so you know I'm struggling with it
in a big way right like it's really
broken it's it's not the reality of the
world we live in
it's you know the whole game I think
that all schools should go
this is for Matt and like like you know
why teachers underpaid because like the
structure go create the school where
it's complete capitalism and every
school's capitalistic and then the best
teachers are going to pay plenty you
know like I mean it's just it's so
broken it's ridiculous most kids are
learning more on their own than they are
in the classroom because they have more
information at their fingertips every
where else back to your question you
know look I don't know the rules every
principal every superintendent runs it
differently like I love the notion of
you texting with every mom in the class
you know communications good kids can't
hide through the structure I hid for 12
years through the structure
I just don't rip my report card up the
second it got to my mailbox and flush it
down the toilet
two by three to six more days of freedom
leaving my mom got wind and punished me
for three weeks that was the game in
today's roll you can email me that you
can send it like think there's a lot of
things to do but through this what I
would implore and when I before my
sister was a teacher do and some of my
other friends my most practical advice
to a sixth grade teacher is to try to
build the self-esteem of the students in
your class that would be that's the
thing I spent my entire life thinking
about which is the only tool against all
the pressures that our kids face is
self-esteem that is be weapon and so I
only have one teacher ever that I saw
now we're winding my brain and realizing
what she was doing that went person by
person in her class and accelerated and
celebrated their unique individual
strengths whether a sports school
personality humor kindness readiness
whatever was she built self-esteem and
that's why I remember